CHRISTOPHER EISGRUBER:
At Princeton, we
recognize that strengthening New
Jersey's innovation ecosystem
enhances a vital aspect
of the university's
educational mission.
Increasingly, our
students and faculty
hope to bring their
knowledge to bear
on social, cultural,
and economic problems
through entrepreneurial
activity.
And our top scholars find that
partnerships with nonprofit,
corporate, and
government sectors
help them to identify compelling
research questions that
make a difference in the world.
PHIL MURPHY: The Incubator and
Collaborative Workspace Rent
Initiative-- we have to
make sure we trademark that.
It's easy to-- add the
R&D tax credit will allow
us to take full advantage
of everything our state has
to offer entrepreneurs
and startups,
as well as our established
innovation-driven companies.
They are welcome additions on
top of the existing technology
business tax certificate
transfer program,
and the angel investor
tax credit program.
And we will continue to grow
our innovation ecosystem
through the EDA's recently
announced innovation challenge
for municipalities.
We have everything right here
to dominate the innovation
economy-- and Chris
referenced this-- the people,
the extraordinary talent,
our location, our history.
We've led this space before.
And through these
programs, we will again.
ANNE-MARIE MAMAN:
This funding program
is focused on some of the
key elements of a startup
ecosystem, funding
and education.
The rent support will
help small companies
to focus their precious
early funding on hiring
and on hitting milestones.
And the emphasis on educational
programming for entrepreneurs
will help to make sure that
our entrepreneurs understand
how to create successful
companies to support
their innovative technologies.
DEBBIE HART: The
medical innovation
that's being
developed right here
in New Jersey by
our companies and
by our academic and research
institutions is second to none.
With more than 350,000
direct and indirect jobs,
over 3,100 life
sciences establishments,
and more than 1,000
drugs in development,
New Jersey is one of
the top three biopharma
centers in the country, and
one of the top 10 innovation
hubs in the world.